[Music]
In this problem, reservoir A is
connected to reservoir B by 4,000 ft of
cast iron pipe, 1 ft in diameter.
Reservoir A is 30 ft lower than
reservoir B. And so a pump with the pump
curve provided in the table below is
being used to transfer water from A to
B. The Hazen Williams coefficient is 110
for this cast iron pipe. At what flow
rate will the pump operate in this
system. Assume both reservoirs are open
to the atmosphere.
So given the pump curve above, we need
to find the closest system head value
available.
The way we are going to do that is by
finding the appropriate version of the
Hazen Williams equation for friction
head loss.
Then we will plug in each flow value
into it and find the total head in the
system at that flow rate. The flow rate
that produces a system head which is
most closely resembling the pump head
will be our answer.
So let's write out our equation.
Friction head loss equals 10.44
L * Q raised to the 1.8 852
over C to the 1.852
* D to the 4.87.
Now we can plug in our known values from
the problem statement.
Note that the units are inconsistent as
the length is in feet but diameter is in
inches. Even 10.44 is actually a
variable given in the reference manual.
So length's going to be 4,000 ft. C is
going to be 110 as given in the problem
statement. And the 1 ft diameter pipe
will be expressed in inches.
So solving this out as far as we can, we
can simplify this equation down to just
the terms H, and Q.
On the left side of the equation, we are
focused on head. The problem gives us
the term for HF, but there are other
head losses we need to account for as
well.
Pressure head can be ignored since both
reservoirs are open to the atmosphere.
elevation head needs to be included
since it's noted that reservoir A is 30
ft lower than reservoir B. Finally,
there is the velocity head to consider.
We could solve for this, but it turns
out that it produces a negligible effect
in this problem, so we can skip it to
save some time.
This means that we just need to add 30
to whatever we calculate for friction
head loss at each flow rate.
Let's do it now.
For 200 gall per minute, the total head
is 30.7, which is less than the pump
head of 49.
For 400 g per minute, the total head is
32.5,
which is still less than our pump head
of 45.
For 600 g per minute, the total head is
35.3,
which is less than the pump head of 40.
For 800 gall per minute, the total head
is 39.4,
which is the first occurrence where
total head exceeds the pump head of 34.
This means that our answer is somewhere
between 600 and 800 g per minute.
Looking at our answers, we can likely
guess that the answer is 740,
assuming that 610 is too low.
But we can check if we have the time.
Since a flow of 600 produces a head of
35.3,
we can assume that the flow of 610 won't
produce much more head than that.
We could check this if we wanted to as
well.
But 740 would likely produce slightly
more than the midpoint between 40 and
34.
So slightly more than 37.
Solving for head when the flow is 740
gives us an answer of 37.9
which is as close as our estimation will
take us.
Therefore 740 is where the system head
most closely matches the pumping curve.
So in this problem, all you have to do
is identify that you need the Hazen
Williams equation
and solve it out for the terms H subf
and Q and then plug in your values of Q
until you can find where the total head
from the flow intersects. The system
head for the